just when we thought that Riverdale
couldn't get any more interesting this
series announced that they'll be
covering Heather's The Musical comes
season 3 watch until the end to find out
which Riverdale cheerleader is set to
meet the same fate as her Heather's
character I'm sure blossom playing the
iconic role of Carrie White Carrie the
musical it's no secret that the
Riverdale cast is gifted with amazing
voices and incredible dancing abilities
and what we're used to Josie and
Veronica busting out a musical number
every once in a while we never expected
this series to come out with Carrie the
musical welcome to carry the musical in
season 2 episode 18 we were surprised
with a musical number unlike any other
while high school dramas usually enjoy
covering musicals like grease or rent
Riverdale chose to go in a completely
different direction the series might
follow the lives of high-school students
but its content is more than a little
terrifying
so the show's creator Roberto
aguirre-sacasa chose to go in a similar
direction author Stephen King has made
his career on writing horror novels and
since Riverdale is tailored around
unsolved mysteries chaotic crime and
teen angst his novel Carrie became the
focal point of inspiration the musical
episodes couldn't have come at a better
time especially since the show's ratings
had begun to slip throughout the episode
9 spectacular numbers were carried out
and flawlessly at that each song
showcased how desperate students were
trying to fit in which caused some
people to commit heinous crimes during
the number the world according to Chris
we got to see how malicious Veronica
lodges mind could be she went on to sing
about what her daddy taught her and how
it's better to hurt others before they
can hurt you
but luckily putting herself in an evil
girl shoes caused Veronica to see from a
different point of view Riverdale's
first musical really set the stage and
now we can hardly wait for its newest
adaptation to come to life and since
Riverdale's Carrie ended with midges
death we can only expect a similar
outcome for the show's highly
anticipated episode jailhouse rock with
the way things ended in season 2 many of
us were shocked to find out that Archie
and Veronica were stronger than ever
after being imprisoned for a crime he
didn't commit
Archie became upon in the wardens
underground fighting bro I'm warning you
you don't want to start with me after
weeks went by without any proper
communication between the two lovebirds
Veronica decided to lift her boyfriend
spirits with a little help from her
friends the river vixens put on their
uniforms and grabbed their pom-poms
hell-bent on putting on the show of a
lifetime but before bringing pep to
their local penitentiary they made it a
point to learn some wicked moves the
river vixens created their own rendition
of jailhouse rock which is originally
sang by Elvis Presley this musical
number was showcased in season 2 episode
3 and it's definitely worth the watch
Riverdale loves to throw in a song or
two whenever they get the chance so what
better way for Veronica to declare her
love than to dance her heart out for
archiekins
at first the inmates lost their minds
over the girls his performances causing
them to rock the fence and approval but
before long the boys returned to their
football game and gave it all they had
although the river vixens had good
intentions the warden saw fit to punish
them for their happiness this put a
damper on Riverdale's performance but
not enough to ruin it for good if the
cast brings half as much pep to their
newest musical episode as they did
jailhouse rock we're in for a treat
Heather's the musical Riverdale is at it
again and this time they're not playing
around it was recently announced that
Riverdale students would be taking on
Heather's the musical for their end of
year production although many of us are
familiar with the Carrie plotline the
same can't be said for the 80s movie so
let's find out exactly what we should
expect from our favorite high school
students the musical episode will be
released on March 20th 2019 so we have
plenty of time to get excited the
musical follows a group of three popular
girls named Heather and one wannabe
Heather named Veronica these four high
school students are as rich as they're
popular and they'll stop at nothing to
protect what's theirs veronica is
allowed to join the group when she
proves herself useful to Heather
Chandler the queen of the Heather's
however her love for the group starts to
dwindle when she's forced to bully
people she used to be close with
although Heather's is a fun musical with
plenty of thrilling heads it harnesses
some very troubling themes dark personal
issues intense bullying violence and
teen angst
all play an equal role in this gruesome
movie turned musical when Veronica is
forced to cover up an accidental murder
she becomes intoxicated with power like
never before
Riverdale is set to perform a total of
nine musical numbers all of which will
be jam-packed with thrilling
choreography and lyrics much like they
carry musical Heather's is predicted to
have a devastating and shocking ending
but what else can we expect from a
murderous musical like Heather's watch
until the end to find out which
Riverdale character is likely to kick
the bucket which stars will be singing
move over Winona Ryder because we've got
a new Heather in town and her name is
Cheryl Cheryl isn't used to being on the
sidelines which is why it's not
surprising to find out that she's
snagged the leading role in the
Heather's musical ten of our favorite
characters are set to take the stage but
not all of them will be leaving in one
piece
Cheryl Veronica and Betty will be taking
the lead as the most popular Heather's
in the school and the highly talented
Josie McCoy is set to play Veronica
Sawyer so it goes without saying that
these four ladies will occupy the stage
more often than not secondary characters
will be played by Sweet Pea Archie
Reggie things Evelyn and Tony oh and did
we mention that there's a new addition
to the cast stay tuned to find out which
mysterious Riverdale student will be
making their grand debut during
Riverdale second musical episode once
again Kevin will be directing the school
play but that doesn't mean that he won't
get to sing along whenever the
opportunity arises many of us noticed
that Jughead didn't sing a single word
during the show's first musical and to
our great surprise he won't be getting
off the hook that easy this time around
in fact according to the show's director
everyone will be singing Jughead
included if you love musicals as much as
we do you're probably having a hard time
containing your excitement and hey we're
on the same page what the actors have to
say about the musical when you audition
for a dramatic TV series like Riverdale
the last thing you expect is to prepare
for a musical but unfortunately for the
Riverdale cast this is exactly what was
expected of them while some actors are
more than thrilled for the series second
musical project others are starting to
look for a way out well tough luck guys
because everyone is singing this time
if there's one person who can't stand
the sight of himself singing and dancing
its cole sprouse knowing this directors
chose to cut him some slack during the
carey episode unfortunately for him his
numbers up so despite being mortified of
his singing and dancing abilities Cole
will undoubtedly take the stage funny
enough Cole's girlfriend Lily Reinhardt
who is known for playing Betty Cooper
also has some bad feelings towards
musicals
however singing isn't exactly her
problem according to Lily her dancing
skills are all over the map which makes
it hard for her to perfect her dance
moves so despite looking like a natural
on camera Lily's less than thrilled to
learn new choreography on the other hand
Camilla Mendes who's known for playing
Veronica is super excited for the show's
newest project and so is her on-screen
ex-boyfriend Archie when it comes to
singing and dancing you could say that
Archie and Veronica are Naturals
all in all we're hoping that working on
a musical will bring Veronica and Archie
back together because let's face it the
show doesn't really make sense without
everyone's favorite couple the
mysterious farm if there's one
organization that makes Betty dig her
nails into her palms it's the farm we
first heard about this cult when Polly
Cooper chose to abandon her hometown to
join Edgar ever nevers magical
Wonderland despite seeming like a crazy
person
Alice chose to follow in her daughter's
footsteps during a period of grief
causing her to become a cult activist by
now you're probably all aware that Alice
gave all of Betty's money away to the
farm you gave my money to the farm which
led them to buy out the sisters of quiet
Mercy headquarters unfortunately for
Betty her mother's total disregard for
her future caused her enemies to get the
upper hand so knowing this we can just
imagine how furious Betty will be when
she finds out that the farm is
sponsoring Riverdale's musical
production for now all we really know is
that something big is about to happen
could the farm be the missing link Betty
and Jughead have been looking for if so
we'll soon find out if Edgar
ever never is the one true gargoyle team
without the Betty's endorsement the farm
has taken it upon themselves to fund the
Heather's musical and this makes us
wonder if they're trying to corrupt a
new group of students into joining their
cult the CW recently posted the musicals
casting list
places the farms very own Evelyn ever
never as miss Fleming on top of that it
also reveals that Jughead will be
responsible for the program security
detail while we don't have all the
details ironed out we do know that the
farm is up to something big
peaches and cream Riverdale isn't
exactly innocent when it comes to giving
their characters ridiculous names names
like Jughead sweetie and things aren't
exactly common well it looks like we're
about to add another name to the list
because an unknown character named
peaches and cream will soon be joining
the production although little is known
about the latest addition we do know
that actress Bernadette Beck is set to
fill her shoes
Bernadette's casting is more than a
little confusing though especially since
her character is set to play three
different roles all of which are male so
we're thinking that peaches and cream
might be a non-binary character luckily
we won't have to wait until the musical
episode airs to find out who this person
is because she's set to make her first
appearance in the bizarro Dale episode
which is set to air on February 6 a
popular theory surrounding the newest
addition to the Riverdale cast is that
Cheryl's ex-lover is going to make an
appearance which should cause tension to
arise between Cheryl and Tony remember
when Cheryl opened up about her first
love Heather well some people think that
she'll be coming back for good with so
much going on we're excited to see what
Bernadette's character will bring to the
plot and if she is in fact Cheryl's
long-lost girlfriend things are bound to
get a little messy so long dear Cheryl
it isn't easy to say goodbye to a
beloved character which is why none of
us want to say farewell to Cheryl
blossom
however the show's decision to bring
Heather's the musical de life makes us
believe that Cheryl is a goner
Cheryl is set to play Heather Chandler
the most popular girl in school and
Heather's character passes away when
she's accidentally poisoned although
we're murder is passed off as a teenage
suicide Heather was actually poisoned by
a handful of chemicals and oddly enough
one of them is Drano
which is known for its bright blue color
and since The Gargoyle Kings victims
tend to pass away with blue lifts people
believe that Cheryl's character will
meet the same fate do you guys think
it's possible that
Jarrell's drink will be replaced with
cyanide and fresh aid while on stage if
so she might meet the same fate as poor
Marge although we'd hate to see this
theory come to life it makes a lot of
sense don't believe us just take a look
at the casting list and you'll see a
little blue drink drawn next to Cheryl's
name before you go make sure to let us
know if you think that Cheryl's
character is about to get killed off and
that's the end of our video don't forget
to subscribe to the things for more
great content to come your way thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]